hank goldberg back here on the Rich
Eisen show how are you Hank you know
rich
I still can't watch the scene for Vito
Corleone is playing with his grandson
and he keels over with the orange rind
in his mouth can't watch huh that's uh
hey you know one quick thing on Al Davis
yes he wants to ask me who got harder
who Darth Vader was argue serious yeah
did he think it was like some some some
fast recruit from they kept saying I'm
like Darth harder
it's unbelievable Hank these worlds that
we live in
all right so we've got we've got a Derby
tomorrow yes we do give me your thoughts
what do you think about it sir
well justify I think is the horse to be
I have a horse that might beat him
because I thought the two best horses
were out on the west coast this year and
both the world who I think is a nice
price at eight to one I'm gonna use
those two horses one two in either order
but I've got a long shot I know you guys
like that we do Hosford training by Bill
Mott ran second in the Florida Derby
they say he looks great and he's
training very well and he's gonna be
yeah he's gonna have to improve some
over that race and I think he will but
you know justify is written by Mike
Smith and both the world has a new rider
Victor Espinoza we'll get him out of
gate well and get him in good position
justified through the seven posts it's a
great draw for him and both the world
out of the 11 hole will be right there
with him I don't like Magnum moon the
other undefeated horse through post 60
who has speed on either side of him and
he could get into trouble early and this
is a good race because you've got pace
in here and I think it's good setup for
a closer like awkward but I like those
horses 1 2 and I'm gonna have them 1 2
and super factors with Hochberg and
acta boxes with Hochberg I'm gonna throw
in a good magic as a possibility to
finish underneath and exactly but my key
horse for the super fact of the run
fourth would be combatant he's fifty to
one and here and fourth in the Arkansas
Derby and third in the rebel he could
have won the rebel against Magnum moon
he's fifty to one Magnum moon is six to
one but in a rebel got slammed out of
the gate got in trouble twice and he was
closing rapidly and he's gonna have a
clean trip from the twenty post and he
could finish you know underneath there
and and hit the board so okay I read use
him underneath and my supers alright so
now let's let's let's let's put it to a
more find you you catch all that Chris
broccoli yeah okay so let's put more of
a fine point on this how confident are
you here Hank I mean cuz it's very very
oh okay I like that I really like that
well I really get both or a chance to
win this race I think that when he ran
against when you ran against justifying
the Santa Anita Derby he was tired off
his previous race and here Ian second
the whole way around and he just
couldn't catch justify now justify some
of the experts say that his time wasn't
that good but Baffert is trained him
harder coming up to this race Baffert's
very high arm he could be if he's as
good as bad for thinks he is he's gonna
do well gone forward to but this horse
he could be tremendous I should mention
Mendelssohn the only thing I like about
him is I had a history teacher in high
school named Mendelssohn but he shipped
in late the fifth course Oh brah that
you're talking about the horse shift is
shipped in like not your teachers gone
higher grand his loss too but you know
Mendelssohn you know didn't come in
until Tuesday thinking it out
quarantine until yesterday was his first
day on the track ain't no Brian is fifth
or be the best I think he's run with his
horses
it's Biff and the problem is they should
always ship these horses in from
overseas too late to adapt to their
surroundings on this track and I think
that about them but he's gonna be part
of the pace early he's he's all about
speed
okay so let's let's recap here for those
you're you you believe justify is gonna
win and how should people box justify
how are you going to box how do you
suggest gonna bust I'm gonna box justify
and both d'Oro with Hochberg and good
magic and I think half burgers is my
best exacta box and I'm gonna play super
factors with justify and hopper on top
mm-hmm when I'm the numbers are 711 like
the score and number nine hopper gonna
need with I'm going to use that twenty
horse at fifty to one underneath and a
super and I think I might throw a good
magic in there too good magic is horse
yeah recap it Brockman over there so
it's the 711 horse to justify and bolt
to or oh three two one and eight to one
as we're speaking right now with hofburg
at twenty to one underneath right the
nine and the six horse the nine and the
6 so a seven eleven nine a seven eleven
six wouldn't be bad and then for a
superfecta seven nine eleven twenty and
six that's what you like yeah and by the
way I would but I will play a super
woods and with the eleven on top to to
back it up there by the way Hochberg is
not going to be twenty to one
he's the wiseguy horse right now okay
and they say he's looked great since
he's got the Louisville Phil Mott the
terrific trainer he'll have him ready
okay Hank if you had one exacta box one
exacta box
you want to leave with our listeners
saying that somebody who's got a little
bit of scratch that they just want to
throw on this Derby what do you have for
me I would play justice I would play a
three horse box justify both d'Oro and
hot perc 7 11 and 9 let's do it okay all
right Hank thank you the man next buddy
take care of yourself Hank we'll chat
before the Preakness hopefully okay oh
yeah for sure all the best to you guys
you bet that's hank goldberg the hammer
at hammering Hank gee the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience